So now that we have a good understanding and overview of what Unreal Engine is and how
the engine affects the editor, we're going to go over the basics and navigate in the
UI.
So you can think about the flow of the use of Unreal Engine starting from the left-hand
side here.
We import all the files.
They turn into this big project, which is housed of a series of UAssets.
And then the editor, the interface that you'll be using, plugs into that project.
So you can interface with all the files.
You can have some tools plugins, as we referred to before, that can supplement the engine's
use.
It may give you some more custom functionality over certain properties and features that
you need for your project.
And then the engine compiles everything.
It cooks to what we refer to as cooking the files and creating an application from all
of these files.
So if we look at the engine versus editor again, the engine accessed via the editor
of Visual Studio.
It contains core tools and systems.
The engine manages all the moving parts, all the under the hood stuff that we referred
to before.
And it also packages the project.
Whereas the editor, it is your interface for adding, editing any of the content that is
there.
There is also sub editor interaction through different windows and browsers.
And it also visualizes all the project's content.
So if you've employed the 3D assets or the particle systems or anything that we were
referring to before, you can visualize all of these with inside the editor as well.
To access the editor, we want to download and launch a project file.
So we want to select the engine version.
You can select the project.
And also there is a vault section along the bottom which will house any kind of free content
that you may have downloaded.
And there is more documentation for reference, but it's sometimes useful to just get a practical
example.
So let's load the launcher ourselves and let's get stuck into a third person template
and show you exactly what we referring to here.